hey I have a very I don't want to spend
a lot of time with this on this we've
had so much stuff on the program already
uh there's a video that came out of a
very disoriented visibly confused Donald
Trump at Mar-A-Lago with Charlie Kirk
standing next to him it's a bizarre
video where Trump says people were
trying to vote for Kerry Lake in Arizona
in miles in five miles long lines and
for 10 hours on Election Day now that
happens to be a lie but let's listen to
what he said the audio is not great but
let's do our best to figure it out weird
lines and the three four five miles long
you don't be good three four five mile
long lines
[Music]
and remember there were a few tabulators
that briefly didn't work
[Music]
broken
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
folks the line went to outer space some
people are still in line today a month
later there is no hyperbole too absurd
for Donald Trump and you know if this
stuff was true which it's not if there
was only something that could be done to
help those voters where it's hot and
they're elderly and they don't feel well
something like where maybe they could
fill out a ballot and then take it to
the post office or maybe leave it in
their mailbox vertically to be picked up
by the U.S us posters Postal Service or
maybe if there were more locations to
vote or maybe if there was early voting
at several hundred locations where
people could go and it would spread out
the crowds if this stuff were true
it would be nice if there were something
that we could actually do about it now
of course we all have to ask ourselves
where was the news coverage of file five
mile long lines Five Mile lines to vote
even Four Mile lines or three mile lines
Trump said it was three four or five if
there was a three do you you realize if
there was a single line that went three
miles to vote
it would have been national news all day
on November 8th and they the only story
was
some lines
and a few malfunctioning tabulators it
really makes you think here's by the way
just another video with the scene at
Mar-A-Lago seems absolutely bizarre here
is Trump I guess looking for Michael
Flynn in a crowd around the same time
that he gave that strange rant
a lot of questions
[Music]
by the way this is Trump at a me at some
event of filled with conspiracy
theorists down there at Mar-A-Lago
[Music]
the food's gonna be good
but it's great to have you uh you know
General Flynn is one of my favorites
he's a great gentleman a great man he's
gone through hell yeah and he's strong
Michael Flynn and other conspiracy
theorists apparently were there Frankie
looks better I saw him yesterday he
looks better than he did 10 years ago I
don't know what's I don't know what's
going on but where is he by the way
where is he come on get over here
general
of that you're a much more handsome man
right now all right it's gotten very sad
Trump's the DJ trumps the maitre d
Trump's the guy who comes through saying
is is there is there a Flynn here is
there Michael Flynn here it's all
getting wacky there were no 10 hour
Waits there were no Five Mile lines You
Love non-fiction books you love learning
as much as you can about politics and
economics and history and science but
you just don't have the time to read
every book that you want to read that's
why I'm such a big fan of blinkist it's
the app that takes thousands of
non-fiction books boils them down into
an explainer that you can read or listen
to in 15 minutes and get the most
important insights from the book you
take a topic you've been wanting to
explore and you can consume 10 books
about it in an afternoon it gives you a
meaningful overview and insight into
what other books you might want to read
in full I just read welcome to the
universe it's Neil deGrasse Tyson's
latest book that's exactly the type of
book that I would love to have the time
to read but my stack of books is already
so big my girlfriend and I also use the
blinkist connect feature to share and
discuss books with one another with one
account and it makes a great last minute
holiday gift you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a
subscription at blinkist.com Pacman the
link is down below